i actually never planned to go into
computer science for a living if you had
told me growing up as a little girl that
was going to be my career path i would
have really thought you'd lost your mind
um i was interested in biology because
of the impact on human health and i
wanted to figure out how i could help
cure different diseases and i was really
excited about that i only got into
computer science out of necessity it was
during my phd that i started on a
project that required capturing a lot of
images on the microscope basically me
sitting at the microscope for four hours
a day
incredibly tedious incredibly boring and
i thought well this this microscope
comes with some software that allows you
to program it and i ended up creating
this monster of a blob of code that
allowed it to capture images and analyze
them that really got me hooked seeing
the power of being able to accelerate
the biology was really enticing to me
i run a research lab here at the broad
institute of harvard and mit and what's
really unusual about it is that we bring
together people at the interface of two
disciplines so normally there's
biologists and there's computer
scientists and we are right in between
those two it's a really cool place to be
because it's uncharted territory and the
synergy of everyone coming together with
their different ideas from different
disciplines really helps to accelerate
our research
so i got into this field because i
wanted to develop new medicines and it's
an increasingly important problem as
it's getting more and more expensive to
find new medicines and on top of that
humanity is finding more and more
diseases that we need to cure
the standard way of identifying drugs is
that you just study a disease for a
couple of decades try to figure out the
mechanisms there's so much that's
unknown and it's just incredibly
painstaking there's still a huge
bottleneck in finding medicines for each
disease
instead of trying to study diseases in
actual humans or even in model systems
like a mouse or a rat what if we could
study the disorders in cells growing in
a dish they're super cheap very easy to
grow and they don't mind if you add
thousands of chemicals to them to try to
figure out if one of them might make a
good drug
so the approach that my lab is taking
involves images so we use microscopy we
use image analysis to see whether we can
identify any unusual structures in the
cells of humans that have particular
disorders we can treat those cells with
different drugs and try to find are
there any drugs that make the unhealthy
looking cells look healthy again one
example of this basic approach is what
we've done with patients who have
various mental illnesses and so what we
thought is well let's collaborate with
someone here in the boston area at
mclean hospital gathering groups of
patients that have very specific types
of symptoms and they've taken cells from
those patients skin cells and grown them
in a dish and then we've looked at their
structure and we were really surprised
to find that we could identify whether a
patient has various illnesses that cause
psychosis just by the structure of their
cells really a shocking finding um but
we're really excited to see that the
mitochondria of the cell the powerhouses
of the cell are
not as not distributed as evenly as they
usually are when patients have these
different forms of psychosis and this
was an incredibly exciting result
because it means we can now take cells
that have this disordered looking
mitochondria and test drugs one by one
using just cells in a dish
this field of image-based profiling to
see that field really blossom and
develop over the past decade has been
incredibly satisfying so when a clinical
trial comes out and our software has
been used to identify a drug for it
there's nothing like that feeling
[Music]